para Ucrania este vehículo podría ser
clave en la guerra contra Rusia el
leopardos de fabricación alemana es
considerado como uno de los mejores y
más exitosos tanques hechos en occidente
solo unas 20 naciones lo poseen y según
el Instituto internacional de estudios
estratégicos con sede en Londres entre
países europeos y miembros de la otan
suman más de 2.000 unidades a pesar de
la voluntad de algunas naciones de la
alianza del Atlántico Norte para ceder
estos vehículos a kiev una cláusula
Establece que su venta o donación a un
tercero debe ser aprobada por el
gobierno de Alemania los leopardos pesan
cerca de 60 toneladas y pueden
desarrollar una velocidad cerca a los 70
kilómetros por hora además cuentan con
un sistema óptico térmico más avanzado y
controles de incendios más modernos un
cañón de 120 milímetros y pueden
alcanzar objetivos que están a más de
5000 metros de distancia características
que supondrían una ventaja frente a
algunos modelos de tanques rusos los
tanques modernos de la otan como el low
Park abrams tienen un sistema de GPS y
cuando se detiene sabe con mucha
precisión Dónde está entonces desde este
punto si tiene las coordenadas de su
objetivo puede destruirlo con un tiro
Esta es una gran ventaja con este tipo
de cañón Ucrania también tendría acceso
a una gama más amplia y más moderna de
municiones de la otan pero expertos
advierten que el suministro de esta
munición a largo plazo podría
convertirse en un problema ya que solo
proveerá Ucrania de artillería
convencional ha obligado a la otan a
acelerar su producción y mantener el
flujo de funcionamiento de los leopard
complicaría más el abastecimiento otra
preocupación radica en el estado de
estos vehículos en agosto España retiró
una oferta para enviar tanques a kiev
diciendo que su estado era lamentable
luego de pasar años almacenados Ucrania
necesitaría alrededor de 100 tanques
leopardos para tener un efecto
significativo en la batalla y el
ejército requeriría una capacitación de
3 a 6 semanas para poder operarlos